it's not a question of will I be a
mother it's a question of when yeah and
I promise myself and I'm sticking to it
that
it will happen it will happen the time
has come for Adrian Houghton to step
into her new role I want to be a mom and
her the real co-host couldn't be more
thrilled after Adrian made a surprise
announcement Tuesday that she welcomed
her first child with husband Israel via
surrogate a baby boy named ever James
the congrats and well wishes started
pouring in God makes no mistakes yeah
and it's all in his time amen and if you
say you believe in him it will happen I
know Lonnie Love reposted that
encouraging clip from a past episode
telling Adrian to never give up on her
dream of being a mom the comedian wrote
ever James will have so much love around
him you are a fabulous mom hashtag
Auntie Lonnie so when we've said dream
big yeah you keep dreaming big I'm
Dreaming I'm Dreaming it and I'm holding
on to that yes Jeannie my Jenkins who
became a mom herself in January to a
baby girl named Monica couldn't contain
her excitement writing Lord thank you
for this gift you spent quality time
making for Israel and Aid every second
of perfection we've been waiting for you
ever Monaco's ready for matching outfits
Tamara Mowry Housley who exited the
talker in 2020 said she cried so many
tears of joy upon hearing the baby news
and garcelle Beauvais wrote your prayers
came true lucky little boy you deserve
to be a mother garcelle continued the
celebrations in her Instagram stories
simply writing her Dream came true as
for Tamar Braxton who left the reel in
2016 she dedicated a post to Adrian
welcoming her to the boy mom Club quote
boy moms are the best moms and anytime
someone is chosen to be a mom is a
direct blessing from God I am beyond
over the moon happy for my family
someone we're thrilled to see sharing in
Adrian's Bliss her former 3lw bandmate
naturi Naughton whom she recently
reunited with
[Music]
naturi gushed in the comments so happy
for you both I think there always was
this idea of like I'm happy for you and
you're happy for me this unspoken thing
but the road to Motherhood hasn't been
an easy one for Adrian who was
vulnerable on the daytime talk show
about her struggles over the past years
not to give up on my dream of being a
mother I literally joke with Israel I'm
like I am either the most resilient
human being or I am wildly delusional we
get these bad notices and it'll be like
and it didn't work this time or you know
I've done multiple cycles of IVF and so
many other things I don't know why I
refuse
to let this be the end of my story I
don't think you can have those
conversations and talk about things
until
you feel strong enough to you know what
I mean and I think there are people that
get strength at different times in their
Journey the 38 year old reflected on her
journey with a heartfelt message after
keeping her baby news a secret for the
past nine months quote he is worth every
tear every disappointment every delayed
prayer every IVF cycle every miscarriage
everything no doubt baby ever was worth
the wait we think Adrian spoke him into
existence years before I want to be a
mom I think that would be like the next
chapter is building a family and um
still being able to do all the things
that I do but at the same time I just
think that would be probably a great way
for my life to come full circle
foreign